[Applaudissements]
Andrea tu l'as vu j'arrive à la fin ah
c'est magnifique pour la dernière
de saison
c'est normal bon justement qui dit
dernière de la saison dit petit
rétrospective des meilleures images a
commencé par nos potes les politiques
qui étaient déchaînés cette saison dans
le gauche à droite
allez on fait l'aller avec Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan qui revenait tout frais de
ses vacances et attention parce qu'il
avait lâché un scoop qui avait eu
l'effet d'une bombe ça fait des années
ça fait des années que je dis que les
éoliennes ne marchent pas quand il y a
pas de vent
es de campagne flambant je baisse
j'éteins je décale
je décale un slogan assez simple quand
même à retenir un peu galère pour
Philippe de Viller quand même je suis
pas très bien compris j'ai essayé de le
répéter je baise je
décale je recale je non je baisse je
baisse c'est ça chaque geste compte je
baise
et attention François brûle le ministre
de la Santé avait fait une déclaration
de la plus haute importance
il faut un certificat médical
aujourd'hui pour faire de la pétanque
super
[Musique]
on croit en tout cas qu'il faut couper
l'horreur robinet il faut couper le
robinet mais il faut aussi couper le
robinet moi je veux couper le robinet je
pense qu'il faut couper le robinet
bonjour Arnaud Robinet bonjour
fin d'année la coupe du monde de foot au
Qatar a une chose est sûre en le député
Jérôme Guedj ne portait pas du tout la
compétition dans son cœur
je pense que le boycott diplomatique
aurait été un signal quelque chose de
gâché pour le pognon faut dire les
choses comme elles sont pour la
géopolitique du Qatar qui respecte pas
les droits humains on peut pas faire
comme si on voyait pas ça
on était sûr qu'il allait regarder aucun
match mais aucun est-ce que vous allez
concrètement regarder les matchs
que je dis mais pas trop ce que je fais
en gros alors un peu un peu d'acturant
cette année avec les législatives de
nouveaux députés tous frais on fait leur
rentrée à l'Assemblée nationale et qui
dit nouveau député Bernard dit plein de
jolies nouveaux petits noms la parole
est à Monsieur Frédéric maillot la
parole est à madame Cécile violon
madame Alexandra Masson
madame Béatrice rouleau
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Claude
Rault
le ministre de la santé était opposé à
la légalisation du cannabis et tout
allait bien jusqu'à la question qu'il
fallait pas poser je ne suis pas à titre
personnel favorable à la légalisation du
cannabis on a maintenant du cannabis qui
est modifié qui est extrêmement
concentré qui est dangereux qui
s'apparente plus à des drogues dures on
a déjà fumé
quand j'étais très jeune il m'est arrivé
de fumer un joint
c'était marqué par des manifs dont une
qui avait lieu au début d'aprèm du coup
BFM a eu la bonne idée d'envoyer son
porteur bah dès le matin logique déjà du
monde autour de vous pour cette
manifestation
non il y a pas beaucoup de monde
et après les grèves une fois de plus
l'autre gros événement était
le beaujolais nouveau est arrivé comme
le veut la tradition il est là le
beaujolais nouveau
merci Pierre-Yves en direct depuis
Pointe-à-Pitre
sans oublier le joli voyage en Chine
d'Emmanuel Macron plein d'infos
primordial Emmanuel Macron donnera
plusieurs cadeaux à son hôte
peut-être un weekend jet ski au Fort de
Brégançon
de la porcelaine de la masse du facture
de Sèvres un vase et également deux
photographies de Marc Riboud c'est de la
merde
ça c'est drôle
on se rend pas compte parce que ces
chaînes d'infos comme ça il faut
alimenter alors ils envoient tout le
temps les mecs tu sais sur les
reportages et des fois ils ont pas
forcément alors il y a du monde non il y
a personne encore donc il faut meubler
et après il te rappelle toutes les 10
minutes
c'est de vous faire découvrir les
pépites de la politique et de la cue
mais pas que on a aussi découvert les
pépites des réseaux sociaux ah oui qui
se déroulait chaque semaine à travers la
France entière et c'était très dur de
faire une sélection des meilleures
vidéos mais je vous propose qu'on lance
la dernière méthode
dans les montagnes après le tout c'était
aussi de comprendre comment ça marche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un gros match était prévu à Guingamp et
même s'ils étaient chaud bouillants ils
auraient mieux fêter
direction Lyon où j'avais trouvé un mec
super chaud au niveau mais un peu moins
pour se rattraper ensuite
[Musique]
un très joli cadeau à La Rochelle cette
mamie avait reçu un nouveau téléphone
portable on va prendre tous c'est aussi
de savoir s'en servir donc là elle
apprend à appeler les personnes voilà
appelle-moi non
cap sur le sud-est tout ça aurait été un
peu chelou si les voitures faisaient
vraiment ce bruit
[Musique]
super héros c'était agrandi avec un
nouveau Spider-Man ah bon on passera
pour les super pouvoirs
et du côté de La Courneuve joyeuse
anniversaire à ce mec qui était très
bien entouré en tout cas
[Musique]
c'était l'heure de relancer la piscine
donc il y a plus qu'à voir la bonne
méthode
je vais la traiter
[Applaudissements]
c'est extraordinaire
Andrea c'est extraordinaire le public
adore on adore formidable
peut-être plus personnel pour vous aussi
parce qu'on a fait énormément ben oui de
quoi merci pour cette saison merci aussi
à Valérie Benaim Benjamin Castaldi avec
qui on a fait beaucoup de chroniques
ensemble et puis bah merci au public
surtout
à toutes les équipes aussi toutes les
équipes techniques toutes les équipes en
régie les équipes qui ont travaillé
aussi sur cette chronique qui ont permis
que ça se fasse toi je dois reproduction
la direction qui m'a permis aussi de
kiffer cette année donc voilà merci pour
ça merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
cette chronique moi je l'adore il y a
que le titre que je redoutais parce que
j'avais peur à chaque fois de me planter
si je leur doutais
rien d'autre allez les amis merci
Bernard merci